[Música]
[Aplausos]
y quien te vendría a dejar y buscar al
trabajo es que no podemos adaptar toda
la empresa para contratarte sojo
enfermarte mucho no deja deja no te
preocupes yo lo hago
pero también su mamá como me gustaría
ser tan fuerte y valiente como vos
es tan inspirador verte venir a trabajar
todos los días y tenerles paciencia para
tus compañeros también es un desafío
ahora no tenemos ningún puesto de
trabajo para vos pero podemos probar con
alguna pasantía
alguna vez le hicieron una de estas
preguntas en sus entrevistas laborales o
lugares de trabajo
si fueran mujeres con discapacidad
probablemente la respuesta sería sí
mi nombre es celeste tengo 34 años soy
licenciada en trabajo social y tengo
discapacidad visceral
tengo no la sufre ni la padezco forma
parte de quien soy
lo que sí padezco son las múltiples
barreras y desigualdades que tenemos que
enfrentar tanto por nuestro género como
por nuestra discapacidad y es que detrás
de esos comentarios y preguntas hay una
serie de ideas y prejuicios que hacen
que las personas actúen y tomen
decisiones que nos terminan excluyendo
de muchos espacios y vulnerando nuestros
derechos
por ejemplo
cuántas mujeres con discapacidad conoce
con cuántas se relacionan día a día
en qué espacio nos ven haciendo qué
en argentina más de 28 millones de
mujeres tenemos discapacidad somos un
montón no
y aún así estamos invisibilizadas y
excluidas de la mayoría de los espacios
principalmente de los laborales
piensen cuántas mujeres con discapacidad
conocen que trabajan de vendedor a
policía actriz médica ingeniera o
abogada
si tuviera que apostar diría que muy muy
pocas o ninguna
porque el total de mujeres que tenemos
certificado único de discapacidad en
argentina el 90 por ciento no tiene
trabajo
de las pocas que tenemos el privilegio
de tenerlo casi ninguna tiene puestos de
liderazgo la mayoría trabaja de obreras
o empleadas y casi la mitad sin
beneficios previsionales
en mi caso incluso teniendo una
discapacidad invisible título
universitario experiencia laboral y
cursando una maestría me fue difícil
obtener un trabajo estable y formal
pude porque logré acceder a través de la
ley de cupo laboral para personas con
discapacidad en el estado ley que al día
de hoy no llega a su cumplimiento
privando a muchas personas de tener un
trabajo
a diferencia de otros países en
argentina no hay ley de cupo para
empresas privadas
de hecho el 71% declara que no tiene
trabajadores con discapacidad
a pesar de que casi el 40% tiene algún
programa interno o política para
promover nuestra contratación
hay algo ahí con los números que no
cierran pero bueno un dato más alentador
es que la mayoría dice que en un futuro
si contrataría a personas con
discapacidad bien no
ahora yo me pregunto
en qué futuro va a suceder esto cuanto
más tenemos que esperar
porque no nos pueden contratar ahora
el lugar de puestos de trabajo nos
ofrecen programas de entrenamiento
laboral y capacitaciones donde casi
nadie de los que participa termina
siendo contratado
entramos así en un loop de
capacitaciones pasantías y más
capacitaciones sin nunca llegar a tener
una experiencia de trabajo formal que
podamos incluir en nuestro cb y que sea
valorado porque nos entrevista
entonces mientras nuestras amigas
compañeras aprenden en sus trabajos
reales y remunerados con sus aciertos y
equivocaciones quienes tenemos
discapacidad tenemos que aprender antes
practicar en pasantías
muchas veces no remuneradas o con pagos
simbólicos bien puestos no reales
por qué
porque suponen que no vamos a saber
comportarnos adecuadamente lidiar con la
frustración cumplir con horarios tareas
ni sociabilizar con nuestros padres o
clientes
como si esto fuera poco si logramos
ingresar a un puesto de trabajo tenemos
más probabilidades de recibir menores
sueldos incluso menores sueldos que los
varones con discapacidad
también tenemos más posibilidades de
estar en puestos para los que estamos
sobre calificadas donde no tenemos la
posibilidad de desarrollarnos
profesionalmente
e incluso tenemos más probabilidades de
vivir violencia y acoso en el trabajo
todas estas situaciones no son productos
de nuestra discapacidad sino de un
entorno capaz y tista que no valora
nuestra diversidad
porque como podemos ingresar al mundo
laboral si en cada etapa nos encontramos
con barreras que no nos permiten mostrar
todas nuestras habilidades y
conocimientos
tenemos que lidiar con procesos de
selección no inclusivos con oficinas no
accesibles y personal no capacitado
tenemos que enfrentar reclutadores y
reclutadores que no tienen conocimientos
de discapacidad y que no han trabajado
sus sesgos entonces cuando nos ven
piensan que vamos a hacer un problema
que vamos a faltar mucho o que no vamos
a ser productivas
tenemos que ir a entrevistas donde nos
hacen preguntas personales y violentas
que no tienen nada que ver con nuestra
capacidad desempeñamos en el trabajo
preguntas sobre si nos bañamos o
vestimos solas o sobre si tomamos alguna
medicación
sin dudas las mujeres con discapacidad
no estamos en igualdad de oportunidades
para ingresar al mundo laboral pero no
porque no estemos capacitadas sino
porque estas barreras se extienden en
todos los espacios y son reproducidos
por todas las personas
imagina en esta situación
mañana se despiertan prender la
televisión
quiere leer los diarios y están en
braille
salen a la calle y solo hay personas con
discapacidad
que se quedan mirando los hilos excluyen
tan solo por no tener discapacidad
como se sentirían
y como les afectaría a su día a día si
esto les pasara todo el tiempo
toda la vida
saben cuáles son las barreras más
difíciles de romper
las que están en nuestras cabezas en
nuestras mentes y eso es lo que tenemos
que cuestionar y cambiar y esas barreras
que surgen de la idea de que hay formas
normales y únicas de desplazarse de
comunicarse de pensar de sentir de ser
y que todas las personas que no
encajamos en esa norma tenemos que
esforzarnos por adaptarnos o quedarnos
fuera
la buena noticia es que como lo normal
es una construcción social lo podemos
transformar para que ni nosotras ni
nadie quede afuera
la mejor forma de aportar esta
transformación es abrirnos a la
diversidad pero abrimos de verdad y
hacerlo ahora ya abrir estos espacios
que no han sido históricamente negados
para que nosotras también podamos estar
porque nuestra sola presencia va a
permitir derribar muchos de esos
prejuicios que nos excluyen porque
nuestra presencia va a permitir ver
estas barreras en acción y pensar en
conjunto formas para derribarlas
la invitación es a comprometernos a
hacer algo incorporar pequeños cambios
liderar pequeñas revoluciones que
inspiren e influyan en otras personas
porque no hacer nada es ser cómplices
preguntemos en nuestros lugares de
estudio de trabajo oa nuestras marcas
favoritas si contratan mujeres con
discapacidad
preguntemos a nuestros gobernadores
diputados senadores si se avanza en el
cumplimiento del cupo laboral
elijamos emprendimientos productos y
servicios de mujeres con discapacidad
apoyemos y visibilizamos las acciones de
organizaciones que promueven nuestro
empleo
no juzguemos a las personas por si
tienen o no tienen discapacidad
conozcamos las
re pensemos y cambiemos todo porque como
esta hora está mal porque si no seguimos
reproduciendo desigualdades porque el
trabajo es un derecho y no podemos
permitir que continúe siendo un
privilegio
porque si nuestras luchas como sociedad
dejan a las mujeres con discapacidad
fuera no avanzamos porque si nosotras no
hay inclusión ni revolución
[Música]
[Aplausos]